ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าคะ
วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันพุธค่ะ
วันพุธที่เท่าไหร่คะวันพุธที่ 27 เดือน
อะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้พ.ต.
2565 ปีค.ศอะไรคะนี้คศ 2  0  2  0  2  2
ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้
วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
ม 6
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตตปีพต 2  565 ดีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวัน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
28 เดือน
เมษายน
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่
โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
12:00 น
เที่ยงกี่นาที 49 นาทีอ่ะ
ก็ยัง 49 นาทีก็เป็นเวลากลางวันเวลากลาง
วันนะคะนั่นโอ้วันนี้ไก่เรามีอะไรคะครู
หญิงเอ้าวันนี้นะคะเราก็จะมีเวลาที่นัก
เรียนนักเรียนนักเรียนเนี่ยมาประเทศไทย
ใช้โรงเรียนมาประเทศไทยเนี่ยบางครั้งนัก
เรียนก็ต้องอาจจะขับรถจะไปถ้านักเรียนขับ
รถมนถนนนักเรียนก็อาจจะเห็น
ป้าย
แบบนี้สวยมีป้าย
ซ้ายอยู่บนถนนหรออยู่ข้างๆถนน
สมัยตรงนี้เนี่ยเป็นถนนนะคะถนนขับรถแต่ก็
ต้องเรียนมองไปทางซ้ายหรือทางขวาข้างๆ
นั่นเองก็จะเห็นเมื่อได้เสวยป้ายเนี่ยก็
จะมี
ภาษาไทยใช่ไหมครับไฟฟ้าให้นายเข้าใจ
ไม่มีมีอะไรคะอันนี้เป็น
มีเนี่ยภาษาอังกฤษใช่ไหมมีภาษาอังกฤษตอน
นี้ภาษาไทยที่ 2 ภาษาอังกฤษแล้วก็อันที่
สามก็จะมีอะไรคะ
อันที่สามนะคะก็จะมีเรื่องอะไรนะลูกศรใช่
ไหมลูกศรบอกนะตรงไปอยู่ทางซ้ายอยู่ทางขวา
สมัยแล้วก็อันที่สี่
มีอะไรคะอันที่ 4 เนี่ยเราเรียกว่าอ่า
สัญลักษณ์จ่ายค่ะเป็นรูปสมัยเป็นรูปที่
เป็นสัญลักษณ์จะไปถ้าอย่างรูปของอันที่ 1
วันที่ 2 วันที่ 3 ก็จะมีมีรูปไม่เหมือน
กันไม่เหมือนกันนะแต่ไม่พาเวลานักเรียนมา
ประเทศไทยถ้านักเรียนอ้อไม่เข้าใจภาษาไทย
ไม่เข้าใจภาษาอังกฤษและถือว่าจะดูรูปใช่
ไหมรูปที่เป็นสัญลักษณ์อันนี้นั้นก็จะ
เข้าใจว่าห้อง
สถานที่นี้คืออะไหล่
ไหมอันยลักษณ์เยอะเลยนะคะครูหญิงชายค่ะ
วันนี้เนี่ยผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้าก็จะมีรูปที่
เป็นสัญลักษณ์ที่ประเทศไทยให้นักเรียนดู
ว่าเป็นรูปของสถานที่อะไรนะคะไม่รู้ครู
ป๋าจะรู้ไหมนะ
อ้ะนักเรียนเห็นหรือยังคะ
เห็นแล้วค่ะครูหญิงเห็นแล้วค่ะเห็นแล้ว
เนาะในรูปเนี่ยเป็นอันนี้เป็นสัญลักษณ์นะ
คะเป็นรูปที่นักเรียนจะเห็นเวลานักเรียน
ขับออกรถหรืออยู่บนรถนะคะลูกฟ้ารูปที่กู
ฟ้าเห็นอันเนี้ยเป็นรูปอะไร
เครื่องบิน
เครื่องบินถ้านักเรียนเห็นรูปเครื่องบิน
แบบนี้ก็หมายถึงสถานที่อะไรคะหมายถึง
สนามบิน 3 ทรายดีใช่ไหมสนามบินอย่าง
ประเทศไทยก็จะมีสนามบินชื่ออะไรคะครูฟ้า
สนามบินสุวรรณภูมิ
ใช่ไหมสนามบินสุวรรณภูมิก็มีเครื่องบินมี
เครื่องบินเครื่องบินนะคะด้วยต่อไป
โอ้ว
อันนี้เป็นรูปผู้หญิงผู้หญิงนะคะและผู้
ชายผู้ชายถ้าครูฟ้าเห็นรูปนี้มันจะหมาย
ถึงสถานที่อะไรคะหมายถึงห้องน้ำ
ถ้าประชายค่ะนี่ห้องน้ำในห้องน้ำห้าเป็น
รูปผู้หญิง
หมายถึงห้องน้ำหญิง
ถ้าเป็นรูปผู้ชาย
หมายถึงห้องน้ำชายใช่ไหมค่ะไม่ไม่มีรูป
ผู้หญิงรูปผู้ชายด้วยกันนะครับประเทศไทย
ยังไม่มีคะยังไม่มีจะจะแยกใช่ไหมห้องน้ำ
ห้องน้ำหญิงช่องน้ำชาย
สายกักห้องน้ำผู้ชายห้องน้ำผู้หญิงแยกกัน
นะคะ
ต่อไปค่ะโอ้ครูมาเห็นรูปนี้ที่รูปเนี่ยมี
คนใช่ไหม
แล้วก็อันนี้ก็คือเหมือนเตียงนอนหน้าโอน
นอนอยู่บนเตียงครูฟ้าก็คิดว่ารูปนี้เนี่ย
หมายถึงสถานที่ไหน
โรงพยาบาล
ใช่โรงแรม
โรงแรมเก่งว่า
ก่อนนะไม่รู้ค่ะใจโรงแรมใช่ไหมอย่างนี้
โรงแรมชื่ออะไรคะครูฟ้ามองเห็นมั้ยเล่น
อยู่เกิลสวยเป็นโรงแรมณโรงแรมก็จะ
มีดาว 1  2
2  3  3  4  5 ใช่ไหมคะอ่ะถ้านักเรียน
เนี่ยขับรถมาแล้วก็หาโรงแรมไม่รู้อยู่ที่
ไหนแล้วก็เห็นป้ายนี้หรือว่ารูปนี้ในก็จะ
หนังใกล้ๆจะถึงโรงแรมแล้วนะคะอันนี้ก็
เป็นป้ายที่บอกว่าเป็นโรงแรมนะคะรูปต่อไป
ค่ะ
อะไรคะในรถในป้ายนี้แก้วแก้วหวย 1
ครูมาคิดว่าป้ายนี้หมายถึงสถานที่อะไร
ร้านกาแฟหรอ
หรือว่า
แม่ค่ะ
ร้านกาแฟสวยก็เป็นป้ายที่หมายถึงร้านกาแฟ
นักเรียนคิดอยากจะดื่มอเมริกาโน่ S เพรส
โซ่นะคะก็เป็นป้ายหาบอกว่าเป็นร้านกาแฟ
ต่อไปค่ะ
อะไรคะ
อ่าครูฟ้าเห็น
ต้มค่ะซ่อมแล้วก็
ช้อนค่ะครูฟ้าเห็นป้ายที่จะมีรูปช้อนกับ
ส้อมฟรีฟ้าคิดว่าป้ายนี้หมายถึงสถานที่
อะไร
หมายถึงร้านอาหาร
ร้านอาหาร
ชัยค่ะแก่
นักเรียนหิวข้าวใช่ไหมหิวข้าวโอ้ยอยากกิน
สปาเก็ตตี้ส้มตำต้มยำกุ้งไปที่ร้านอาหาร
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงไปต่อไปนะคะพูดทำไมเลขจัดขอขยาย
นิดนึง
ในรูปนี้ครูฟ้าเห็นอะไร
ครูฟ้าเห็นรถรถเมล์ไม่ใช่รถเมล์รถเมล์ใน
ประเทศไทยในป่าจะมีหมายเลขนะคะ 77
ต่อไปก็จะมีหมายเลขของรถเมล์หรือว่าเบอร์
รถเมล์
รู้ฟ้าเห็นป้ายที่เป็นรูปรถเมล์ครูซ้าย
คิดว่าเอ๊ะอันนี้รถเมล์ไหม
รถมีรถบัสรถเมล์รถบัสรถบัส
ครูฟ้าเห็นป้ายที่เป็นรูปรถเมล์หรือว่ารถ
บัสครูปังคิดว่าหมายถึงสถานที่อะไรหมาย
ถึงเอ่อ
ที่
เรียกว่าอะไรอ่ะที่จอดรถ
ประจำทาง
ป้ายรถเมล์ใช่ไหมน่ารักดีค่ะป้ายรถเมล์
เอ้อป้ายรถเมล์ป้ายรถเมล์ป้ายรถเมล์นัก
เรียนใช่ไหมความหมายถึงป้ายรถเมล์ที่
ปุ้ยนะคะที่ที่ประเทศไทยจะเป็นแบบนี้นะคะ
นี่ละตายรถเมล์สมัยนักเรียนยืนรอรถเมล์มา
ดูซิว่าครูป๊าคิดถูกไหม
ใช่ค่ะอ้าวมันคืออะไรคะมันก็หมายถึงป้าย
รถเมล์ได้นะครูฟ้าเนาะง้อมันก็เพียงรูป
คล้ายๆกันนะฮะแต่มันอาจจะหมายถึงอันนี้
เราเรียกว่าถ้ารถมาหารถกันใช่ไหมถ้าครู
ฟ้าหมายถึงป้ายรถเมล์ก็คือครูฟ้ารอรถเมล์
ใช่ไหมแต่ถ้ารถก็คืนถ้าครูฟ้าคิดกูฟ้ามี
บ้านอยู่พัทยาแต่กูฝากคิดไปมา
กรุงเทพฯหน้าไหนมากรุงเทพครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่
มีรถขับรถแหละไม่มีครูบาก็ต้องนั่งรถถั่ว
ไม่ได้เราเรียกว่ารถทัวร์หรือว่ารถ The
Last
Row ฟ้าจะต้องหน้าเวลากูฟ้าคิดจะนั่งรถ
ทัวร์มา
กรุงเทพฯก็ต้องไปที่ท่ารถเงินจะมีรถทัวร์
พัทยากรุงเทพ
พัทยาเชียงใหม่พัทยาภูเก็ตพัทยาเกาะช้าง
ใช่ไหมคะถ้ารถมีละเนาะรอรอรถทัวร์
ไม่ใช่รอรถเมล์นะคะ
งั้นล่ะล่ะถ้ารถจะอ้ออะไรรูปนี้นะครับๆ
ต่อไปหรอในรูปนี้ครูฟ้าเห็นอะไรคะลูกค้า
เห็นเอ่อแป๊บนึงนะอันนี้
เตียงค่ะจะเห็นเตียงฮื้อเห็ดอะไรอีกไหม
อันนี้เนี่ย
สัญลักษณ์นะคะอ่าของ
โรงพยาบาล
ตรงหน้าไปนี้หมายถึงสถานที่อะไรคะ
โรงพยาบาลค่ะพยาบาลใช่ไหมเวลาเราไม่สบาย
ก็ไปโรงพยาบาลนะคะ
ในรูปนี้ก็คือโรงพยาบาลณโรงพยาบาลอะไรคะ
คือฟ้าในรูปนี้โรงพยาบาลกรุงเทพใช่ไหม
เป็นเวลาไม่สบายเราก็ไปโรงพยาบาลนะคะเก่ง
มากค่ะจะไปต่อไปนะคะป้ายนี้เนี่ยเปลี่ยน
สีไหมเมื่อก่อนป้ายสีน้ำเงิน
ไปนี้สีเขียวนะคะในรูปครูฟ้าเห็นอะไรขอดู
ฟ้าเห็นคน
คน
คนนะคะทำอะไรตีกอล์ฟ
ไม่มีไม้กอล์ฟด้วยนะคะกำลังตีกอล์ฟครูฟ้า
คิดว่าป้ายนี้หมายถึงสถานที่อะไรคะ
หมายถึงสนามกอล์ฟค่ะสนามกอล์ฟไปดูว่าไง
ไหม
โอ้โอ้โอ้โห
ใส่ค่ะค่ะดีก็คือสนามกอล์ฟใช่ไหมคะนี่
เป็นอะไรนะหลุมกอล์ฟเหรอตุ๋มพัดกบพัน 2
ใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็อันนี้ครูฟ้าอยู่ที่นี่ไม่
เป็นอะไรนะคะชื่ออะไรนะครับเห็ดรู้
มีไม้กอล์ฟไงมีไม้ตอกแล้วก็มีลูกกอล์ฟ
เสียใหม่และผู้ฟ้าก็ผัดกอล์ฟเรารูปกล่อม
หน่อย
หมุนลงเจาะหลุมภูฟ้าจะต้องไปตีกอล์ฟที่
สนามกอล์ฟนะคะในหายใช่ฟ้าตีกอล์ฟได้ไหม
อ่าเกมค่ะพี่กอล์ฟในเกมได้นะคะนี่ก็แล้ว
ก็มีไม้กอล์ฟแล้วก็ตีไม่ได้ไม่ได้ไม่ได้
รูปต่อไปค่ะค่ะอู้อู้ครูฟ้าเห็นอะไรคะครู
ไฟล์
จะบอกลามะ
กูมาเห็น
กวางตัด
สัตว์
ครูฟ้าคิดว่ารูปนี้หมายถึงสถานที่อะไร
สมัครหมายถึงสวนสัตว์สวนสัตว์ใช่มั้ยสวน
สัตว์ก็คือเราไปดูช้างแป้งไปดูสิงโตไปดู
ยีราฟใช่ไหมคะ
ที่สวนสัตว์
ใช่ฆ่า
สัตว์สวนสัตว์น้องก็จะมียีราฟมีม้าลายมี
ฮิปโปโปเตมัส
สวยมีปลามีเพนกวิน
สวนสัตว์กูว่าชอบไปสวนสัตว์ไหมลูกค้า
ไม่เนาะประเทศไทยร้อนในประเทศไทยร้อน
ไปต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้าเห็นอะไรอ่ะอือ
กรุกูมาเห็นคนคนใส่หมวกมีหมวก
ขายของครูบาคิดว่าป้ายนี้หมายถึงสถานที่
ไหนหรือว่าสถานที่อะไร
ตลาดค่ะตลาดนัดไปดูว่าอ้อ
จะไปฆ่าเขาไปนี้หมายถึงศาสตร์ได้ไหมเรียน
ไปซื้อผ่านนะคะซื้อหมูซื้อไก่ไอ้ตลาดคน
ไทยหน้าร้อน
ir ใช่ตลาดค่าย
ป้ายต่อไป
ครูฟ้าเห็นอะไร
รูปมาเห็นวงกลม
เห็นวงกลมวงกี่วง
7วง
1  2  3  4  4  5  5  6  7 นะวงกลม7วง
ครูบาคิดว่าป้ายเนี่ยหมายถึงสถานที่อะไร
หรือว่าหมายถึงที่ไหนสนามกีฬา
สนามกีฬาสนามกีฬาก็คือเวลาเราไปดูฟุตบอล
วอลเลย์บอลบาสผลบอล
ใช่ไหมค่ะหนามกีฬา
อันนี้คือสนามกีฬาในประเทศไทยนะคะชื่อว่า
ราชมังคลาจ่ายราชมังคลานิเป็นสนามกีฬาที่
มีที่สุดมีคน
เยอะโทษนี่นั่งแล้วก็ดูได้มากที่สุดใน
ประเทศไทยตอนนี้นะตอนนี้นะคะฉันนาฬิกา
น้องสนามกีฬาราคามากๆ
รูปต่อไปครูฟ้าเห็นรูปนี้ครูฟ้าเห็นอะไร
คะ
เรียกว่าอะไรนะที่เติมน้ำมันใช่มั้ยเป็น
เหมือนที่นี่นี่นะคะแล้วก็มีน้ำมันอาจจะ
เป็นเบนซินดีเซลแก๊สโซฮอล
ครูฟ้าเห็นป้ายนี้คิดว่ากฎหมายถึงสถานที่
อะไรคะหมายถึงปั๊มน้ำมันปั๊มน้ำมันไปค่ะ
สมัยปั๊มน้ำมันอย่างในรูปนี้เนี่ยก็จะ
เป็นอันนี้เป็นภาษาไทยเนาะปั๊มน้ำมันปตท
ใช่มั้ยฮะก็คืออันนี้นะที่เติมน้ำมันแล้ว
ก็จะมีรถใช่ไหมรถก็จะขับมานะคะแล้วก็เติม
น้ำมันอ่ะชะนีค่ะต่อไปค่ะค่ะอู้ในรูปนี้
ครูฝันเห็นอะไรคะอ่า
ครูฟ้าเห็นเก้าอี้
เก้าอี้แล้วก็อันนี้ครูฟ้าคิดว่าอะไรดอก
ไม้ค่ะดอกไม้หรอแล้วครูฟ้าเห็นป้ายนี้ครู
ฟ้าคิดว่าหมายถึงสถานที่ที่อะไรคะสวน
สาธารณะนะที่สวนสาธารณะก็คือเราไปวิ่งไป
ไปวิ่งเราไปจ๊อกกิ้งไปปิกนิกอาหาร
ใช่ค่า
Way
สวนสาธารณะในสวนลุมนอนลุมพินีนี้คนอะไรไป
วิ่งนะคะ 1 รูปแล้วกัน
รูปนี้ครูฟ้าเห็นอะไรคะ
แจกันค่ะเป็นแจกันก็คือมีเราสามารถใส่ดอก
ไม้ได้นะคะเป็นส่งมาครูฟ้าคิดว่าว่ารูป
นี้เนี่ยป้ายนี้ในรูปนี้นะคะหมายถึงสถาน
ที่อะไรคะ
พิพิธภัณฑ์
พิพิธภัณฑ์แบบ
เราไปดูของเมื่อก่อนใช่ไหมอ่ะอ่า
ใช่ๆ
พิพิธภัณฑ์ใช่ไหมเรามาดูของเก่าหรือว่าไป
ดูดูแบบนี้นะเราเรียกว่าพี่พิพิธภัณฑ์
เหมือนแบบ British  Museum สมัยดังๆก็จะ
เป็น
ป้ายนะคะที่บอกสถานที่ในประเทศไทยชนะเคย
เห็นไหม
ประเทศนักเรียนเหมือนกันมั้ยก็คอมเม้นท์
บอกทาง LINE
ผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้าก็ไปก่อนนะแล้วเจอกัน
วีดีโอหน้าบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะดีมาก